كادت يا استاذ مشاري انها تحصل لحظه
الثوره
المهديه هي لحظه جوهريه جدا في التاريخ
الحديث
اللي هو اواخر القرن التاسع عشر ليش لانه
باعتبارها انها اول دوله بعد ثوره
حققت جوانب وطنيه حقيقيه
وكانت في محاوله تاريخيه ايضا اللي انه كل
هذه الاصوات وكل هذا الاختلاف انه تستوعب
والتناقضات تستوعبها خطاب واحد اللي هو
دوله ممكن تقول عليها دوله وطنيه عرفت
التجربه كانت مهمه جدا انت تعرف انه
في هذاك الوقت
قلت لك في البدايه كلام ابن خلدون اللي هو
غلبه اللغه بغلبه اهله شاعل لسان العربي
وسبق هذه الثوره
ممالك اسلاميه معروفه يعني ابتداء من
القرن العاشر الميلادي
ظهور حتى اكتملت الاركان ايوه سلطانات
دارفور عرفت اسمها كثيرا
وعلى فكره يعني
التاريخ الاسلامي تحديدا عرفت في دارفور
اللي فيها الان الصراع وصراع حول الهويه
والموارد بشكل اساسي
يعني
لهم اسهاماتهم المباشره في تاريخ تطور
الدوله الاسلاميه عرفت فيك فيك في في
الشرق وفي الغرب في الشام في المغرب خاصه
وحتى اليوم على فكره في علامات كثيره
تحيلك بشكل مباشر الى الى مراكز الحضاره
الاسلاميه الى مراكز الخطاب الاسلامي بكل
جوانبه الى اخره
بالاضافه لوسط السودان اللي هي مملكه سنار
يعني عرفت مملكه سنار اللي هي كانت
من اوائل الممالك هي الدوله مكتمله
الاركان اللي هو حصل فيها
صلح شهير جدا بين العناصر اللي هي افريقيه
عرفت هو العناصر العربيه اللي هو ما يعرف
الفونج والعبد الله بن عبد الله بل هم
الاب هذه اب النسبه في عربيه اهل السودان
اللسان العربي حتى بعد الاستعمار
البريطاني في الوثائق الرسميه ومنها اول
دستور عام 1953 وحتى اخر الدستور اللغه
العربيه هي اللغه الرسميه
الدوله اي نعم من فتره طويله جدا بالاضافه
لانه القرن 19 والقرن ال 20 شهدوا عدد
هائل من الدراسات ومن المؤلفات